today I'm an Edinburgh the capital of
Scotland the landmark of the city
Edinburgh Castle stands proudly on the
skyline I'm taking a stroll down the
Royal Mile the most famous street in
Yaletown
Scottish culture seeps out of every
corner and I'm going to throw myself
right in there and have a whisky before
dancing the Scottish people have always
been very proud of their own traditions
their back pipe music whisky kills and
also Scottish dancing Edinburgh is the
perfect place to learn those dances
because it's the home of the Royal
Scottish country dance Society it has
been training dancing instructors for
almost 100 years and now I'm off to take
a lesson
Stuart Adam has been teaching Scottish
country dancing for more than 40 years
coordinating dance clubs and organising
balls and he's won many awards thanks
that I can learn Scottish country dance
and that was already the first step I
saw right was the time to practice it in
a circle
this is a setting step for dancing on a
spot my jumping could look a bit more
graceful it feels weird only using my
feet I would like to do it's not a lot
use your hands in the next time now we
are dancing in sets a typical
configuration and when I leave the line
is very important again is who I follow
and where I have to come out to three or
four pairs form sets and change
positions according to strict patterns
sometimes everyone dances sometimes just
one pair and sometimes too confusing in
the 18th century it was mainly Arastoo
Kratz who danced it wasn't until much
later that it became part of for culture
the dances have remained true to their
origins well done good it's exhausting
but how do you memorize all these dances
because the progression is always
different what do you do from that's
called the pilling book okay everything
in simple pictures turn circle come up
to the top how many dances out in there
yes and this book there's about 500 okay
so that's an easy way of memory it it's
like the Bible
unfortunately I don't have my own cheat
sheets so all I can do is keep
practicing
it's not that easy to know when it is my
turn and which position I have to dance
but it will have to do the Royal
Scottish Country Dance Society has
invited me to its Spring Fling and I had
better be on time you don't need a
partner for the Spring Fling because
it's dance informations and everyone
switches around dancers from all over
the world have come here to see it
performed Scottish country dance is
really about friendships and it's really
an international community it's fun you
get to meet lots of people it's
brilliant exercise it's great music it's
just a whole lot of fun
I've worn a checked scarf to match the
men skills
I'm not always sure when it's my turn
but luckily it's hard to notice in a
group like this I'm not so keen on those
little hops and jumps but that doesn't
matter
Scottish country dancing is all about
old and young coming together in simply
having fun
and thankfully my partner knows where we
are going that makes one of us